[no sound]
[music playing]
William Wang: This performance with the Pops
is
probably one of the most
exciting ones that I've done.
It's my first time playing with
a professional orchestra.
[music playing]
Wang: The focus of my PhD is machine learning
and statistics and I'm investigating theoretical
questions, like how much data do you need
in order to actually make a good decision.
It's great having music as an outlet to just
be able to do something in your free time
and to just kind of switch your mind out of
research and focus on something different
and activate different areas of your brain.
I think my younger self would be elated to
hear that I was playing with the Pops because
I would always watch a YouTube recording of
their Stars and Stripes Forever performance.
And I was always inspired by that.
I would just watch that every
4th of July so… [laughs]
[music playing]
Wang: When you come into the practice rooms
at MIT, you're supposed to disinfect the keys
before and after you practice.
And then it just makes a sound like... it
just sounds like this.
[random notes from piano keys]
So you just hear that in the practice
rooms a lot when people
are coming in and leaving to practice.
[piano keys playing in lower octave]
[random notes from piano keys]
[music playing]
I gave a recital recently that had just a
few members of a live audience.
I had to wear a mask
when I was performing.
The rest of the people watched it on Zoom.
So it was nice because I could have
my friends in California watch.
[music playing]
[music changes]
Wang: So I chose to play the
Rachmaninoff concerto because,
first of all, it's a great piece of music.
And it's just also very close to my heart
because I've been playing it for quite a while.
I learned it four years ago.
I do like the first movement for
its beautiful lyrical themes, but
there was some also
deeper angst, I guess.
The solo sections of this
piece are very intimate.
And there's a lot of beauty in them.
They're very passionate and loving, but it's
also kind of sad and bittersweet.
[music playing]
I guess in a time of pandemic,
sometimes you don't want to
plunge into something completely new.
Maybe different people have different ways
of coping, but I like to go back to what I
originally liked and rediscover
what I liked about it.
[music playing]
Wang: I think one of the most important things
about music is that you can kind of take away
what you want to take away from it.
There's a lot of interpretive history that
different people play it different ways.
I hope that my particular way of playing resonates
in you and somehow brings you joy.
[music concludes]
[no sound]